what's happened to la it it kind of
i i always thought of la and in even
california for sure
as kind of that hot blonde from high
school
that was always the bell the ball didn't
have to study very hard
phone rang every friday night for a date
really was able to kind of get by in her
looks and kind of cruise
and now that blonde is 47 years old
and not the bell of the ball anymore and
you know if you listen to gavin newsom
that guy i've heard interviews with him
going hey man where are you going to go
it's like it's like the 47 year old
blonde
saying to the the football star hey
don't you want some of this
and it's like no no i i can find
some of that's in texas or arizona or
nevada
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report joining me today is a
best-selling author
co-star of the wonderful documentary no
safe spaces and host
of the adam corolla show podcast adam
carolla welcome back to the reuben
report
always good to be back dave all right
corolla we got a lot to do here because
this is my last interview of 2020
and we said who can we get on the show
to end the year
that is not completely [ __ ] bananas
and you were on the short list there
were only about two other people we
couldn't get them so
we got you you're on the shortlist of
dave rube insane people how does that
make you feel
you know when i write my next
autobiography
it's going to be titled from the short
bust
to the short list the adam corolla story
nice to be on the short list yes you you
have done it my friend all right first
off i got to ask you something because
there is a rumor going around town
my guys my team seem to believe this
rumor
that you're moving to texas now when i
talk about short lists
on my short list of la people i got adam
corolla
i got dennis prager i got larry elder
john voigt
that's it are you are you leaving us
you're going to houston
no not just yet i did a hit on tucker
carlson
uh i guess last week and they brought
the van to my house and uh
tucker always does the when you leave in
la and i think
he he grew up in i think la and san
diego
so a lot of the guys and uh him and
shapiro
are the two when you he leaving la guys
because they were in la and they
they left and i've always been in la so
just off the cuff because we're in this
van
that was a satellite van i just as an
im comedian i just said oh tucker as
soon as this hits over i'm gonna
commandeer this van
and i'm driving to houston and for some
reason
that didn't come across as a joke to a
lot of people but
you should have seen that it was a joke
people because i
if i was going to houston i would
certainly do it on the southwest flight
i don't think i'd commandeer
you wouldn't 150 000 satellite vans
wouldn't take the satellite van from fox
news and drive that all the way to texas
you do it
first class on southwest i get it i feel
like
just from a mileage standpoint it would
cost much more to take that satellite
van
all right so i'm glad to hear it sounds
like you're staying for a little bit but
i did have you over for dinner a couple
months ago and you said you were on a
three-year plan
and we're watching cali just fall apart
i'm a native new yorker but i've been
here seven years you're
you're from socal man what the hell hell
is going on here
yeah my kids are just getting into high
school if you want to call it getting
into high school because i
walked into both their bedrooms this
morning they're both laying in bed with
their covers over them and i went hey i
thought it was school time and okay
we're on the zoom class
from underneath a comforter um
you know what's happened to la it it
kind of
i i always thought of la
in in even california for sure as kind
of that
hot blonde from high school that
was always the bell the ball didn't have
to study very hard
phone rang every friday night for a date
really was able to kind of get by in her
looks and kind of cruise
and now that blonde is 47 years old
and not the belle of the ball anymore
and you know if you listen to gavin
newsom
that guy i've heard interviews with him
going hey man where are you going to go
it's like it's like the 47 year old
blonde saying to the
the football star hey don't you want
some of this and it's like
no not i can find some of that's
in texas or arizona or nevada or
nashville
tennessee or whatever but there's a kind
of a thing where it's like when you're
used to being the belle of the ball
you don't study that hard you don't try
that hard i mean california
was always like we got the beaches we
got the mountains we got uh
all we got disneyland we got all this
great stuff so it's like well what about
how hospitable you are to business well
don't worry about that
we got malibu right and
what they didn't really factor on i mean
there's a few things
first off smart people don't want to
just hang out and be
essentially abused by their government
that's that's number one
number two there's a part of it that's
just practical like
i grew up out here my parents my mom had
a vw
squareback she had like a 70s vw station
wagon my dad drove a vw
bug forget about driving to arizona
we couldn't get to van nuys from north
hollywood without the thing
vapor locking and like i talked to a
friend of mine uh
dickie from the boss tones the lead
singer from the band the boss tones
and he was like yeah i moved arizona i'm
like oh so you got to go it's like
the drive's not bad i got a great car
it's it's it's got why
you know it's it's got serious xm and
it's in a
heater in the seat and it's like it's
it's not that big of like physically
the transportation you know the the ten
flights a day that are
going from uh burbank to phoenix or jet
swedex
you know like you can get to salt lake
city in uh 55 minutes like
there's a there's a kind of tangible
mechanical part of this
which is when i was a kid if you wanted
to move like
buying a ticket on an airline was a big
deal like packing up a ryder truck
again physically didn't have cars that
could make it
you know it's it's all kind of doable
now
so so what do you think the future of
this
town is i think you probably have a
couple hollywood friends that still talk
to you i've got one or two that would
not be happy if i mentioned their name
um but do you think that this town is
just now
condemned between garcetti at the at the
city level and newsom at the state level
do you think we are just truly condemned
and now gascon this
new d.a who's not going to arrest people
for prostitution or resisting arrest
or a series of other things like how
much worse can it get do you think
well maybe just a little bit and then
maybe it's time
like you know like a horrible alcoholic
maybe this is the
i've stolen my kids piggy bank i'm gonna
break it open to buy some malt liquor
and i now catch a glance of myself in
the mirror
and i've hit rock bottom like maybe that
see you in the mirror thing maybe we're
there
i was thinking about gaston it's like
loitering is not going to be a problem
trespassing
not going to be a problem underage
drinking is not gonna be a problem
prostitution's not gonna be a problem
and i thought where the [ __ ] was this
guy when i was in high school
i couldn't really use this d.a when i
was in high school not only that you can
steal
up to 900 that's what they're telling
you so you could steal a playstation 5
and like seven games but you go into the
eight game range now you're in trouble
yeah it it it all seems like a very
eerie harbinger but
i here you you brought up hollywood like
our hollywood friends
um if you think about this
uh los angeles hollywood la
always been the sort of hub of
production right
and everything was filmed everything
every tv show
anyone ever saw around the world was
filmed in
you know burbank or culver city
or somewhere in hollywood i mean i've
been on all those
all the i've been all the stages i've
been all the lots i used to
be at hollywood center studios doing the
man show and
we did crank anchors there i did love
line there
and at a certain point they started
getting greedy they
started over regulating they started
over taxing and so what did
the most liberal people on the planet do
they started drifting into atlanta
they started going to canada started
going to prague i mean
they literally just left so it was
called runaway production
and at some point some semi-sober person
thought
we can't just have all of this money
just physically leaving the state
and they course corrected a little bit
they were like well why don't we offer
some incentives
for these businesses hollywood not to
leave the state
to do all as as i probably told your
audience
um i drove from this
studio where i am sitting right now
uh brian cranston came in and did the
show brian's a good guy
probably one of the more liberal guys in
hollywood and uh
he said like i gotta catch an uber to
burbank to the burbank airport and i
said i'll drive to the burbank airport
it's four miles away
so we jumped in my car and while we were
driving there he was explaining that
breaking bad was supposed to be filmed
out here but of course they're going to
new mexico to film and of course they
lost all that money and all the tourism
dollars and all that kind of stuff so
at some point they kind of wised up and
they said let's give some incentives
for these guys to stay and i got to
believe
at some point they're going to try to do
that with business
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our comedy
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell